while most restaurants are empty right
now
some are still running but they look a
little different it all happened really
fast as you know we definitely didn't
have any time to prepare you sort of
just winged it this restaurants making
300 meals but none of it's going to the
dining room they're cooking for
frontline workers to deliver meals for
nurses doctors and EMS workers not only
are they making hundreds of the same
meals they're trying to stay healthy and
keep the restaurant open in a time when
most aren't making it it's a lot of bulk
cooking and requires a lot of space and
planning last week we gave these huge
burritos like what we imagine if someone
got off a hard day's shift like what
they would want to eat programs like
this had popped up across the country
New York San Francisco Los Angeles the
business model is simple donations pay
for restaurants to make meals that are
then sent to essential workers out on
the front line one nonprofit frontline
Foods has raised five million dollars in
donations so far we decided to collect
some money and send some frontline
workers some full price meals from local
restaurants and then eventually that
starting to go fund me we raise a lot of
money really fast
frontline Foods has partnered with a
thousand restaurants in 56 cities so far
the organization has donated four
hundred thousand meals one of frontlines
partner restaurants is black bard in New
York City another organization off their
plate has the same business model
started in Boston the organization has
raised four million dollars and it's a
hundred partner restaurants have made
nearly 400 thousand meals golden diner
in New York City was one of its first
restaurant partnerships it was a
no-brainer we get to do something that's
socially and morally positive on top of
that they would be helping support us as
a business to bring back a lot of our
staff
Goldin diner is a small shop and was
able to keep on 90% of its staff
thanks to off their plate more
contributing to the payroll costs which
is top priority
across town black barn is a huge
restaurant just four of Mike's a hundred
person staff stayed on to make meals for
frontline workers and their work day
looks a little different they're cooking
during a pandemic
so obviously safety comes first all
employees have to bring a change of
clothes we also supply shirts and aprons
we also do daily temperature checks
golden diner sanitizes door handles
every hour and has sanitizer buckets at
each workstation and black barn
employees wear gloves and masks while
cooking the week before we have to make
the food we get basically a call sheet
of how many meals where it's going as in
which hospital it's going to and you
know what time so whether it's a lunch
or dinner or breakfast milk both
restaurants have to cater to food
restrictions vegan vegetarian so we some
of these these deliveries every every
week meet all the chefs get together and
we're like okay what are we gonna do
this week so we always have like a
protein a starch a little side and then
we always have a salad frontline food
pays black Barn $20 per meal golden
diner gets $10 per meal from off their
plate the chefs order ingredients from
their same suppliers but the cooking
process has changed to accommodate so
many meals you're cooking for 300 or 200
you sort of have to just like do
something where you can just get it hot
and like get it on a plate also
everything has to be made in bulk
instead of using just one small rice
cooker now we cook rice in the oven and
like these large hotel pans remember
black barn is big so it's got the
kitchen space but golden diner had to
convert its dining room into prep and
packaging space well just put all those
tables together and we'll just play it
all the food once everything's cooked
it's packaged up car
are lined up and filled one by one we
either cold or last long they wouldn't
have any issues holding then
everything's labeled each with the
restaurant and dishes name finally
they're bagged and loaded up for
delivery off their plate used to provide
bands for delivery but it got a bit too
complicated you actually play just like
a social media blast out asking if
anyone would be interested in helping us
out and so now we have our own volunteer
drivers from the beginning restaurants
working with frontline foods needed to
deliver their own meals black bar calls
ubers but it's not always easy we're on
our way to need the contact now to drop
off what is roughly around I believe
over 2100 meals that we've delivered
since the start of this pandemic then
Mike hands off the meals to hospital
workers it was just one of those things
that it took away the burden of having
to figure out how to do normal life
things while we were taking care of
patients and I felt like for my tneows a
great way for them not to have to leave
kovat positive unit to go outside go to
like a deli go somewhere and expose
anybody else right now off their plate
orders make up about 20% of gold and
dinars business but with no dine in
service to support his restaurant in
terms of profits we're not really seeing
much of that it's just sort of
sustaining and neither is black barn but
the programs are helping keep the
restaurants ovens on until they can
reopen for dine in service for now
they'll keep feeding all those hungry
workers out on the front line just
excited about what we're gonna serve
them this
you
[Music]